[Musique]
sur 500 x ou encore plus récemment marc
singer quelles que soient leurs projets
les frères bogdanoff étaient
inséparables
pourtant le duo de scientifiques
emblématique s'en est allé à 72 ans et
seulement six jours d'intervalle grichka
puis igor bogdanoff nous ont quittés
après des informations il serait décédé
des suites du coc vie de 19 alors qu'ils
avaient fait tous les deux le choix de
ne pas se faire vacciner travers les
médias de nombreuses personnalités ont
tenu à leur rendre hommage après avoir
passé leur vie à étudier le ciel et les
étoiles grichka et igor les ont
finalement rejoint un jour l'un d'eux
vous mourra avant l'autre sas est une
perspective ça s'est passé
ce soir ses proches et des qu'andré
pierre jean chalencon sont avec nous
pour leur faire un dernier au revoir
merci
cédric et merci pierre-jean d'être avec
nous
c'est vrai que on se demande tout ce qui
s'est passé parce que on a appris la
mort de grichka c'est vrai qu'on s'y
attendait pas du tout moi j'ai encore vu
trois semaines grichka il était en
pleine forme qu'est ce qui s'est passé
en fait il ya trois semaines il allait
effectivement très bien on a même eu une
très longue conversation parce qu'il
souhaitait même vous faire une surprise
cyril va te faire une surprise on peut
bien sûr y est venue trop bien sûr
d'accord
et il allait très bien
contrairement à tout ce qui est dit
jusqu'à présent
il n'était pas contre le vaccin il faut
bien faut bien préciser les choses il
paraît qu est-ce que c'est vrai que il
prenait jamais de médicaments igor et
grichka exactement la même si jamais ils
n'ont jamais pris de leur vie il était
complètement anti médicaments il se
soigne et quasiment que par les plans
team il avait un régime alimentaire qui
étaient aussi partis alliés délirant de
rennes c'était quoi manger des graines
et manger des graines
grain ils boivent pas d'alcool d'actes
m'enfin c'est ce que de l'eau de l'eau
ils nous avaient jamais et buvait jamais
d'alcool jamais d'alcool
même dans les soirées mondaines dans
lesquelles ils allaient ils prenaient ou
un jus de fruits ou de manger des
graines et voire même il s'abstenait de
manger ou de boire dans les soirées dans
lesquelles elles ces dernières semaines
on devait d guinée plusieurs fois
ensemble chez des copains et chaque fois
ils arrivaient enfin les grands pas on
arrive mais on il n'est jamais pour
dîner quoi c'est ça exactement mais ils
n'ont jamais eu de deux mois je là j'ai
eu la chance de leur faire une fois à
manger à la maison ouais ils ont mangé
par
marc politesse si je puis dire mais ils
ont mangé un coup de fourchette et donc
et pas plus ces malades n'ont jamais été
malades n'ont jamais eu recours à des
alors en fait pourquoi il était contre
le vaccin n'était pas contre le vaccin
c'est que il se pensait insubmersible
tout ça c'était des garçons qui étaient
les années 60 ans déjà il faisait
beaucoup moins comment quand tu vois
qu'igor une riche 470 au bâton mais moi
j'ai un ipad 2 d'un il est c'est
incroyable je les ai croisés la dernière
fois je t'avais dit à igor qui était rue
de lille et il était en vélo je vois ce
gilet pare-balles lui j'ai pas mal mais
moi je suis un peu comme ça quoi et
j'avais pas reconnu et puis ça a dit
alors tu me dis pas bonjour j mais c'est
toi 60 et il est à manille t il des
regarde comme je suis musclé pourquoi
pourquoi ils sont pas faits pour les ont
pas fait le vaccin pourquoi parce que il
était il considéré qu'ils étaient en
bonne santé et considéré qu'il faisait
du sport il considérait que pour eux
tout allait très bien et encore une fois
igor et grichka était vraiment dans un
monde différent du commun des mortels a
alors igor et grichka moi de ce que je
sais c'est qu'ils ont ils ont attrapé le
coc vide en même temps sept ans
exactement comment ils ont retrouvé
vraiment le exactement c'est celle 1 qui
leur fils a notamment dit c'est ça faut
savoir qu'il ne passait pas une journée
un quart d'heure sans se téléphoner sans
se voir sans être ensemble ils habitent
et orbi pas très loin 10 ans ne savait
pas que grichka nous avait quittés
exactement c'est ça le tennis c'est à la
fois le plus grand drame et en même
temps peut-être
quelque chose tant mieux pour imaginer
deux frères vampires
calme-toi pierre-jean je sais moi je les
aimais beaucoup mais c'est vrai qu'il ne
savait pas donc il ya bientôt y le ils
le savaient pas
jusqu'à depuis six jours il était encore
en réanimation
depuis six jours
c'était la fin n'était pas inéluctable
mais c'était tout comme et qu'est ce que
nous ont dit les médecins nous ont dit
tout de suite parce que ce qui s'est
passé apparemment c'est qu'ils étaient
chez eux il avait le coït ils n'ont pas
pris la notion n'ont pas pris la notion
de riz qu'ils prenaient pas de
médicaments se sont pas du tout soigner
même pas un doliprane rien du tout et on
a vu leur état se dégrader se dégrader
se dégrader qu'est-ce qui a fait que les
frères bogdanoff sont allés à l'hôpital
qui leur a dit 'oui' mais est-ce qu'ils
ont été de leur même bien est ce qu'ils
seront tombés dans le coma on est on
sait pas de leurs présidents
locaux vides lorsque le colis arrive à
une certaine forme
inéluctable de réanimation c'est un
problème respiratoire c'est ça donc il y
à un moment donné ou pour ceux et celles
qui qui font des crises d'asthme
connaissent ce que c'est que de manquer
de respiration ou ceux qui sont donc à
un moment les îles sont voilà on est
obligé d'appeler il ya un moment donné
leurs fédérations étaient très faibles
ça l'est de moins en moins bien et la
lonase décision d'aller à l'hôpital a
été précieux vous avez dit joindre vous
de leur dire d'aller à l'hôpital avant
moi je les ai eus au téléphone très
régulièrement au cours de ces derniers
mois ce qui est extrêmement bizarre
c'est que lorsqu'on aborde un sujet sur
lequel ils n'ont pas envie de répondre
à la limite vous ne comprenez plus la
question que vous leur avez posé au
départ et il vous emmène dans une
théorie totalement délirante et et c'est
ce qui faisait à la fois leur charme à
leur foi leur gentillesse parce que
c'était deux garçons d'une d'une
gentillesse absolument incroyable en gt
n'importe qui pouvait les a causé dans
la rue même un cierge en chalencon lille
l'ordre alors il leur griller
il est il était extrêmement gentil avec
eux est vraiment c'était vraiment
vocation quand ils sont arrivés à
l'hôpital leur état s'est dégradé très
vite ou d'un but grichka tout est allé
très vite ils ont dit les médecins tout
est allé très vite ils ont les amis tout
de suite en réanimation
malheureusement il y en a un qui est
parti il ya six jours et l'autre nous a
quittés aujourd'hui alors il ya luc
ferry qui est qui a réagi la ministre de
l'éducation et a mis des freins à bonal
depuis peu très bonne amie traître qui a
révélé d abord engueuler au sujet du
vaccin c'est vrai j'aurais dit 50 fois
de se faire vacciner contre le quotidien
neuf on en a encore parlé au téléphone
il ya moins de trois semaines quand tout
allait bien pour grichka comme victor
n'était pas anti vaccins ils étaient
anti max pour lui même je lui disais que
c'était gros textes qu'ils étaient fous
c'est à dire il jugeait pas les autres
qui pensaient que c'était bien de se
faire vacciner mais eux pour eux c'était
il pouvait pas l'entendre le souci est
encore une fois c'est que il était dans
un monde qui est totalement parallèle
aux ados tous
igor et grichka faisait du sport quasi
il faisait de l'escaladé
ce que moi je suis incapable de faire et
aurait sportif sans un gramme de grève
n'a 31 ans dale carr croyait que le
vaccin était plus dangereux dans l'art
pour eux il ne tombait jamais malade
même leur menton ce n'est pas une
maladie s'était juste du botox c'est luc
ferry cas qui a révélé ça ils me l'ont
dit sauf qu'à 72 ans le système
immunitaire n'est plus aussi performant
qu'avant quelle bêtise mais quelle
bêtise voilà c'est vrai que
moi il ya quand même rire quelque chose
que j'aurais aimé te dire cyril lui
parce que c'est six mois c'est mon avis
ça c'est très important que tu le saches
moi il m'est arrivé de les prendre des
centaines de fois dans ma voiture dans
paris et il ya une chose qui qui les
faisait mourir de rire et c'était le
bloc dabo gab bogdanov et les chansons
et je dois vous dire que c'était quelque
chose qui les faisait absolument ouvrir
de rire c'est des garçons incroyable
c'était il avait eu une autodérision qui
était qui était absolument génial et
mais vraiment il est aimé beaucoup et
moi je les aimais énormément ça faisait
partie de la famille serment alors on va
revoir leurs premières télés dès le
départ et de son lit et quand ils
viennent présenter sur tf1 leur chute
libre clé pour la science fiction
regarde
deux garçons vous en doutez si vous
voulez regarder bien grâce aux caméras
de jacques pierre sans doute est ce sont
des frères et qui fusaient des frères
jumeaux il s'appelle igor et grichka
bogdanoff vous êtes né en france oui
nous sommes nés en france de peyrusse
notre père est originaire de la région
de saint pétersbourg et il est arrivé au
lendemain de la seconde guerre mondiale
en france et par ce concours heureux de
circonstance aux menées dans le
sud-ouest de la france
leur immense force était d'être
différent et cette différence a fait
qu'ils se sont crus intouchables là et
du coup c'est vrai que quand ils sont
arrivés le 15 décembre à l'hôpital
georges pompidou à paris leur état était
déjà très très sérieux et c'est vrai
qu'à ce moment là très vite
selon les informations qu'on allait les
médecins ont jugé que les difficultés
respiratoires étaient tout de suite
énorme si je puis dire ils sont arrivés
très tard trop tard à l'hôpital eq te
mens 3 l'option l on avait trop tard
sélection ils sont arrivés trop tard et
ils ont encore une fois pris ça avec une
désinvolture
totalement hallucinante
ils ont peut-être si on devait retenir
quelque chose
2 aujourd'hui c'est peut-être
moi je suis annie impro vaccin ni un
anti vaccins je suis vacciné j'ai les
trois doses mais peut-être que si leur
exemple pouvait amener à quelques
personnes à convaincre quelques
personnes qui ne sont pas encore
vaccinés qui ont l'âge de l'île de ré de
grichka ou peut-être même un peu moins
jeunes et se dire que ça n'arrive pas
qu'aux autres
peut-être allez vous faire vacciner sans
ce que dit fabrice parce que on le voit
un le cadet des frères bogdanoff is it
est en parfaite santé par âme et sans
dents parfaitement abel qu'ovide ils ont
laissé traîner les choses c'est ça hein
passé et apparemment c'était trop tard
ils ont cru qu'ils allaient pouvoir se
guérir eux mêmes sans rien faire en fait
de cette maladie
avant de dire le côté motion parce que
c'est hyper émouvant et bien je viens
d'écouter merci c'est ce qu'on appelle
la théorie des systèmes complexes ils
ont commis une première erreur ils n'ont
pas voulu se faire vacciner ils ont
commis une deuxième erreur qui est ne
pas réagir au moment que la maladie
démarrer il faut jamais laisser traîner
une maladie moi j'ai des passions qui me
lisent ce que j'ai et grave non il n'ya
pas de maladie grave il ya juste des
maladies tonton son n'occupe pas
correctement et donc quand on s'en
occupe correctement il ya toujours plus
de chances de s'en sortir
donc c'est vraiment ça le message mais
moi j'ai trouvé ça hyper émouvant parce
que moi je ne les connaissais pas mais
j'ai lu le bouquin j'ai pas vu les
émissions j'ai lu le bouquin c'est c'est
génial c'est des gens qui avaient une
étincelle de génie c'est pas des
personnes qu'on croise tous les jours
dans la rue des personnes qui peuvent
avoir cette capacité à nous faire rêver
la question qu'on peut se poser c'est
que ces cd c'était des grands
scientifiques à l'époque d'un avenant
vraiment et je peux vous dire d'une
intelligence à croix et d'un savoir
incroyable c'est étrange qui n'est pas
voulu se faire vacciner parce qu'il
connaissait mine de rien on se dit voilà
c'est pas dit c'est que les gens qui
quittent et sa chance et deux hommes de
science des associations ce silence il
faut il était dans des domaines qui
étaient quand même de relativité de deux
théories de big bang de deux théories de
primaire de
de la création du monde de l'infini est
ce qu'il y aille pas infini alors moi
j'en ai parlé pendant des heures avec
eux et puis au bout d'un moment vous
lâcher complètement prise parce que vous
savez même plus même plus ce que la
question vous leur avez posé et il ya
quand même et il ya quand même la
science médicale qui écopait autre chose
oxo il faut avoir fait des études de
médecine c'est la science de convaincre
en discuter en dehors de la caméra pour
cesser le temps qu on donne à quelqu'un
c'est chercher chez la personne qu'il
est la bonne fibre quel est le bon
argument vous savez on peut convaincre
quelqu'un avec des arguments
scientifiques mais il en a d'autres qui
n'ont pas besoin d'arguments
scientifiques c'est plus dans l'humain
et il faut chercher prendre le temps et
pouvoir convaincre les personnes
convaincre c'est pas de faire violence
c'est pas te forcer à suivre ce que je
pense convaincre c'est de faire adhérer
à un projet que tous les deux nous
allons partager le problème c'est qu'en
général on à lire avec des gros sabots
celle aiguilles tournent toi je vais te
piquer et ça ça marche pas avec des gens
qui sont effectivement un niveau au
dessus de la mêlée quoi ils sont quand
même largement au dessus de la mêlée
quand même avoir rien d'autre alors
c'est sympathique il y en a beaucoup
fait parler c'est celui de périco
légasse qui a affirmé sur et sitôt de
risque avait payé cher son choix de ne
pas se faire vacciner regarde voilà que
la responsabilité il savait bien qu'il y
avait des morts chez les gens qui se
vacciner pas peut-être qu'il considérait
que lui échapperait ou qu'il voulait
prouver que le vaccin n'était pas
obligatoire eh bien il a mené une
bataille il a mené un combat visiblement
il l'a perdue je sais pas si c'était ses
valeurs à lui mais en tout cas il faut
le prendre comme ça c'est quelqu'un qui
s'est penché sur 7 sur ces questions et
il en meurt bon bah il faut savoir
assumer voilà il faut mourir pour des
idées sur ce coup là visiblement il
s'est trompé et il a payé cher voilà
c'est très gentil il est très gentil ce
monsieur il est très gentil de dire il a
pris un combat d'abord il est qui pour
parler au nom de igor et grichka qui
aujourd'hui sont plus l'arrêt ce film
c'est tellement facile moi je vais vous
dire quelque chose depuis six jours
et des tonnes de personnes qui sont ou
étaient ses agents ou et s est attachée
de presse où étaient ses amis
aujourd'hui j'ai eu je ne sais combien
de coups de téléphone de personnes qui
m'ont dit et moi je les connaissais pour
ceci et cela moi ça fait dix ans que je
les connais ça fait dix ans que je les
ai
trimballer avec
d'émission en émission et il ya des
tonnes de gens qui nous était très aimé
j'ai jamais gens mais quand tu vois ça
tu aimais bien sûr parce que on choisit
pas de mourir ont choisi non mais
franchement écoute c'est un combat qui
aurait pas pris une capote tout cas mais
papa il qu'ils attrapent le sida c'est
pareil il ya un moment faut rater ces
conneries quoi igor et grichka
ses grands amis mais puis c'est des gens
que je connais depuis l'âge de 16 17 ans
j'ai enfin tu vois il ya des gens ont
raillé parce que j'ai dit que 30% de mon
carnet d adresses avaient disparu depuis
18 mois est bas alors oui c'est vrai et
alors de façon vous y passerez tout ça
on va tous y passer mais quand enfin le
plus tard possible serait le mieux oui
mais pas pour tous ces manières ya 30%
de tes amis qui sont mobiles peuvent pas
du tout vide mais on a d'ailleurs entre
robert là tous les gens qui sont morts
depuis hier sur gorre igor et grichka
tuer il y aurait caché je les connais
depuis que je suis gamin on les a tous
connu avec ça avec avec gonzague saint
bris avec
tous les copains quoi
c'est des gens qui ont fait la valeur
qui ont fait le temps à mesure que leur
ami tu leur as dit se faire vacciner tu
leur as dit tu le manges tu leur
présence à l'hôpital à moi je l'aurais
pas parler de ça parce qu'à chaque fois
on délirait sur napoléon sur le palais
et c'est la dernière fois que je vais
les voir ce que voulaient les invitent
ils devaient faire le clip de
je suis dans cette chanson est il en
réalité ils pouvaient pas venir bon
après jéhovah se voient on va se revoir
on devait dîner ensemble chez une copine
italienne chez cristaux avec christophe
kulikov qui que tu connais et à chaque
fois ils sont pas venus la dernière fois
j'ai une copine qui les a vus c'était
pour un caveau à la salle gaveau voilà
mais
honnêtement ça va être une perte parce
que ces garçons avaient un tonus vous
avez tout ce que lui vous avez tous
fréquenté bon c'était la joie de vivre
aujourd'hui a plus personne ils vont
nous manquer considérablement que j'aime
ce que dit périco légasse pour moi est
proprement scandaleux mais quand même
c'est scandaleux c'est à dire c'est tout
ceci dit pas c'est bien çà
et là c'est honteux il faut savoir que
les bogdanov qui étaient ces singuliers
étaient de grands scientifiques et pour
eux et pour eux la rationalité c'était
la base de leurs recherches ils
cherchaient des choses et là ils ont
estimé que le vaccin ne leur ferait pas
sans doute à tort toutes les garanties
de sécurité qui n'avaient pas toutes les
connaissances qu'ils n'ont pas mené un
combat anti vaccins maisons jugées pour
eux mêmes ne pas vouloir se vacciner
mais mais mais ses déclarations - elma
abasourdi c'est dégueulasse de dire ça
alors c'est mon jeu et je vais même vous
allez plus loin la plupart de ces de
leurs proches étaient vaccinés et voire
même c'est eux qui les incitaient à
aller se faire avec tibet c'est juste
pas sérieux il ne vous pour eux en fait
considéré vraiment encore une fois ce
n'était pas dans la cible qu'ils étaient
en pleine forme qu'ils avaient
d'alimentation qui leur permettait de
vaincre toutes les maladies du monde
entier
malheureusement ils se sont trompés le
résultat est là aujourd'hui mais ça
n'est encore une fois pas un combat anti
vaccins alors cent d'avril de 79 qui ont
fermé
leurs chroniques à leur concept de son
émission temps x est le premier grand
rendez-vous de science fiction en france
jusqu'en 87 ses partenaires invitent une
émission culte regarder
février 1828 dans une petite île battue
par les vents mais un écrivain dont
l'oeuvre extraordinaire traduite en plus
de cent seize langues restent encore
aujourd'hui celle qui est le plus lu
dans le monde entier il s'appelait jules
verne avril 1926 un écrivain américain
décide de créer une revue dans laquelle
il publiera des textes de prophétie
scientifique dit il et comme il n'est
guère satisfait de ce terme il va en
créer un autre qui fera littéralement
fortune science-fiction avril 1979 pour
la première fois en europe et créer un
magazine de télévision entièrement
consacrée à la science fiction temps x
series conseil ont fait pâques moi je
savais pas quel âge ils avaient des
bogdanov ou les croyait immortel on se
dit c'est vrai que les bogdanoff il ne
voulait pas le dire d'ailleurs
de pudeur voilà et je crois que ce qui
les a toujours
maintenu dans l'espoir c'est un jour de
refaire temps x alors moi je sais qu'en
disant je ne peux pas citer le nombre de
fois où ils m'ont dit ça y est en x va
revenir ça y est on sûr on fait un
pilote national là on a failli
d'ailleurs je vais vous montrer les
images dans un instant on va faire un
pilote payant canal plus avec eux ce que
vous avez pu aller les voir aller leur
rendre visite à l'hôpital où c'est quand
la dernière fois que vous avez vu cyril
quand vous êtes en réanimation car s'il
ya une personne en france qui vous dis
aujourd'hui qu'ils ont été voir igor et
grichka à l'hôpital aujourd'hui lorsque
vous attend ce soir l'irak animations
même pour un scanner ou pour annie rm
aujourd'hui vous rester à la porte de
l'hôpital la personne va faire son
scanner ou son irm personne vous dire à
personne je vous le dis personne n'a vu
personne à part les médecins qui se sont
occupés formidablement bien deux avec
lesquels j'ai pu avoir la chance de deux
communiqués parcimonie vraiment parce
qu'ils l'ont pas ils ont autre chose à
[ __ ] que de de donner des nouvelles de
pierre paul et jacques et igor et
grichka delà d'un feu rouge et avait eu
au téléphone il était il était pendant
trois semaines et de trois wagons
étaient mois là il était en trois
semaines jeu pour pour être très honnête
il ya trois semaines on
on devait te faire une surprise vraiment
il ya un restaurant qui est pas très
loin d'ici carrières sur seine qui fait
des raclettes et des fondues savoyardes
dans des télécabines
ils sont venus manger ça et
ils ont dit je veux à tout prix a mené
une prend d'une télécabine la mettre sur
perçu rideau sur un camion comme une
soucoupe volante il l'emmenait sur le
plateau de thé pnp pour faire bouffer il
tend du savoyard d'art sur le thème
plaisir série là c'est la dernière fois
que vous c'est sert exactement mais
alors temps x on vous dit on a des
images d'un pilote on a tourné voilà
d'une nouvelle émission avec igor et
grichka c'est une exclusivité voilà qui
devait peut-être arriver à l'antenne
alors bien sûr c'est avec tristesse 1 on
se dit que ça va pas arriver à l'antenne
et que igor et grichka nous nous ont
quittés regardez c'est des images
exclusives
souvenez-vous jusqu'au début du 20e
siècle on était convaincus
nivet existait depuis toujours qu'ils
étaient éternels mais oui seulement
voilà en 1922 le génial mathématicien
russe alexander friedman puis en 1927
l'abbé lemaitre ont tous les deux des
couverts par le calcul sans jamais avoir
communauté entre eux que l'univers mais
cofidis est oui selon la théorie le
cosmos ses piges il grandit à chaque
instant mais comment en être certain oui
eh bien c'est de là que celui qui est
considéré comme l'un des plus gros noms
de tous les temps entre en scène voilà
donc c'était pas mal hein est arrivée à
l'antenne voilà on avait fait plusieurs
pilotes et c'est vrai que ces voiles ac
s'est dramatiquement on était fan mal
absolu de igor et grichka qui était
vraiment des amis alors on a vu un serré
qu'il ya plein de gens voilà je vous dis
qu'ils ont réagi au décès de igor et
grichka et à leurs avocats notamment m
edouard de lamaze d'avocats de grichka
bogdanov qui avait dit qui a réagi à
tous les commentaires autour de son
décès et qui était un petit peu énervé
qui de tous les gens qui disent c'est
parce qu'il s'est pas fait vacciner
c'est parce que c'est vrai que c'est
compliqué dont on a un vilain c'est
franchement
ces commentaires - m'ont bouleversé mon
éminemment choqué j'en ai discuté avec
valérie parce que
encore une fois il n'était pas dans un
combat ils n'étaient pas des prosélytes
de des antilles bac c'était pour eux
mêmes c'était un choix pour eux mêmes et
je feins jusqu'au bout face et c'est une
immense dignité pour moi voilà je suis
ému mais ils ont été parfaitement digne
tout le temps donc qu'on insulte pas que
personne ne se permet d'insulter leur
mémoire alors ses jambes selon lui très
souvent sur votre plateau j'avais fait
une nouvelle édition qui s'appelait la
foule à paul est arrivé mais évidemment
chanson life s'était lui chante les fans
en carton chez les termites et toujours
sont mes premières j'étais avec eux les
les bonnes odeurs parce qu'à chaque fois
une porté chance c'est vrai que je les
adores y est c'est vrai que j'ai
tellement ri que j'en ai vomi regarder
et leur frein
on connaît pas fait le plein de
tradition et du sud ouest
[Rires]
j'ai répondu cas de quoi
le gars il est dans son
c'est pour ça que j'aime à grouiller
ambitieux
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
battue et j'ai vomi oui
c'est vrai il ya eu un autre moment
aussi c'est quand ils ont dansé avec
clara morgane
les bogdanov c'était un très très grand
moment aussi je vous dis j'étais pas là
cités je pense mes invités préférées
voilà je le dis c'était bon client mais
vos clients on apprenait toujours bien
et est intelligent s'il avait
l'intelligence voilà de rire de tout je
les aime vraiment très très fort à
l'époque de nos fins
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ils ont dormi
allez
[Musique]
alors qu'ils jouaient jouer complètement
autre chose avait même un jouet à
l'époque c'était de donner le numéro de
benjamin castaldi
j'ai pas eu beau rappeler et les
bogdanoff ya longtemps que vous l'avez
pas fait c'est très bien il avait réussi
à faire eux aussi regarder regard des
élèves se transforme en 014 ainsi ce que
nous avons déconné on a eu beaucoup de
difficultés pour ils correspondent à
quoi c'est arrivé mais ça ils voudraient
pouvoir effectivement en place et dont
l'interprétation est donc nous avons et
nous l'avons fait et donc nous avons
fait venir il est donc temps à mal se
passer qu'est-ce qui a réculé
démonstration vous devez faire là
d'accord là il était donc de 15 salles
bus nous dit quelque chose de très
précis
[Applaudissements]
non mais c'est vrai qu'ils jouent le jeu
il y avait un autre extrait jouer
montrer ces îles avec 40000 talons
c'était notamment d' excellent
guitariste et chanteur et les bogdanoff
et les gars font vous allez voir ça
c'était un des grands moments de
rigolade avec les bogdanoff aussi
regarder
[Musique]
angers
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
igor et grichka nous ont quittés c'est
vrai qu'il ya eu il ya eu même des
rumeurs comme quoi il n'y avait plus de
72 ans mais c'est vrai que ça et 72 ans
il avait 72 collègues ici moi avons
beaucoup moins c'est incroyable c'est
son cancer la chirurgie esthétique ouais
c'est vrai que c'est luc ferry qui a dit
à cannes et qu'ils aient fait du botox
on le disait jamais non ya pas que le
botox mais oui parce que le botox ouais
ouais beaucoup autour de la table qui
savent ce que ça fait merci castaldi
en tout cas pas dire voilà on peut dire
que c'est qu'ils adoraient rigoler il
adorait ils vont beaucoup banques et
avons beaucoup manquer à la terre bien
sûr énormément énormément manqué ils
vont manquer à la france parce qu'elle
était adoré mais vraiment et ils ont
aidé beaucoup de jeunes se voient ils
ont je vous même vous dire quelque chose
votre assistant de deux plateaux théo
dire oui que vous connaissez en devenir
je vous jure que c'est vrai la première
fois
qu'il est monté à paris on était à une
séance de dédicaces chez gibert jeune
vous pouvez le faire venir en plateau il
vous dirait que c'est vrai il est entré
il aurai je vous jure que c'est vrai on
igor et grichka ont pris le temps j'ai
pris le temps de leur présenter et ils
lui ont donné plein de conseillers plat
les gens étaient vraiment me dire on
aura on n'arrivera jamais à parler des
bogdanoff au passé parce qu'on les aime
exact mettra d'autres extraits de mein
encore de igor et grichka parce que je
les aime voilà je vous dis je parlerai
jamais dos au passé parce qu'ils seront
toujours avec nous et font partie de la
famille on les aime on les aimera
toujours